[Applause]
please welcome someone i am one of the
biggest fans of justin sutherland
drew
thank you so much for having me it's
amazing now
what are we making because macaroni and
cheese is my favorite food on planet
earth
but i've never seen this i know well i
do know that macaroni and cheese is your
favorite food so that's why we're making
it it's pasta wheat i know that come on
okay
sorry i'm back no it's okay i never left
but i'm i'm very excited yes will you
teach us how to do this oh my gosh that
would be like my biggest pleasure in the
world let's do it yeah i feel the same
way
um now we're starting with a roux yes so
you should have some butter melting
right there in that pot yep all right
so here's our butter here's our butter
we're gonna throw all that in
and mixy mixy mixy and what you want to
do i mean technically it should be equal
parts to flour and butter and you're
going to get kind of that peanut buttery
color right there uh we're going to take
our some milk milk yup and we're going
to add that in and incorporate it with
our roux here
and that flour and butter is what's
going to help thicken that up
all right so we have our little spice
blend here we've got some onion powder
some garlic powder some smoked paprika
cayenne a little black pepper dump it
all in
so then after that so normally we'd let
that reduce down a little bit it's going
to get a little thicker but we're going
to slide right over here you mean like
that like this and that is the thickness
that we want our roux with our spices to
be yeah so here's where our mac and
cheese gets a little bit different so
normally we would just do heavy cream
but we have a mixture of sour cream and
cottage cheese here and what that's
going to do it just adds a little
acidity kind of that just extra oomph
that you're not going to get from a
normal cheese sauce so this makes ours a
little different so just go ahead and
dump that right in your little bathtub
this is this is really beautiful i love
a sour cream cream cheese approach i'm
all in
so here we have we've pre-melted a
little american-style cheese and that's
just going to give even more creaminess
more cheesiness make your bathtub even
more delicious
are you melty over there i am i'm
melting everywhere
let's add some pasta there we go
and i don't there's not enough calories
in here yet um so we're just going to
finish it off by mounting it with some
butter because butter makes everything
better and the butter is going to give a
little thickening action it's like that
mouth feel it's velvety it coats it i
mean butter does so many things so i
think our pasta is perfect right now
we're going to take our spoon i think
you have a bowl over there
however much you want we're just going
to spoon right into this bowl
so here's where our mac and cheese gets
a little bit different we take these hot
crispy cheesy flaming flaming puffs and
we are going to put those all over the
top
as much as you would like
i'm going to center it look at that
plating
wow from you
the amazing chef are you kidding me
thank you
i cannot believe justin you would say
that thank you and oh and then a little
i mean if it depends if you like them
pre-crushed if you want them whole if
you want a little bit of both
you do your thing girl
should we have some bon appetit cheers
thank you so much for making mac and
cheese with me true thank you so much
for teaching me how to make your
beautiful mac and cheese
i mean
this is so layered so pleasurable
so not what you think it's gonna taste
right
i will say
it really puts a new spin on mac and
cheese i kind of thought i was going to
have familiar territory not at all it's
that sour cream it's the crunchy
bits on top it's a little cheese pillows
you completely transformed the dish it's
incredible i'm just going to take one as
you should as you should yeah no it's
incredible thank you thank you so much
thank you so much
new episode
on thursdays at 10 p.m on true tv one of
my favorite shows and also catch
taste the culture with justin sutherland
on youtube which is where you go and
explore women yes um throughout the
country and their culinary backgrounds
women just bypack just just you know
people of color and females and telling
untold stories in the food world that
you know would normally not get a
platform so you know i would take the
spotlight off me and go find new stories
that need to be told all right well
we'll be right back
[Music]
you